most Chinese people are acutely aware
that for most of human history China has
been the most powerful country in the
world so they look at the last couple of
hundred years as an anomaly because
China has been a poor and a weak country
rather than at one of the strongest
countries in the world and so they want
to build China's comprehensive national
power they want to be in the Premier
League but at the same time they're very
cautious about how this is done there's
a perpetual fear within China that other
countries will decide that China's a
threat and will try and unite against it
and balance China's rise and try and
contain China so therefore for a long
period of time even talking about
China's rise was was practically a taboo
there was a sense that if Chinese didn't
mention it other people might not notice
that that it was happening and that's
why people talk a lot about the peaceful
rise of China and you know various
attempts have been made to try and
reassure the rest of the world that
China's not going to be a threat to give
them to give other countries a stake in
China's rise to show that it's a win-win
situations have failed fame favored
Chinese phrase the idea of win-win and
basically tried not to frighten the
horses so that's one very important
characteristic of how they're dealing
with it and it's part of the fact
they're so self-aware about about their
power and and how it grows and that
leads to a series of policies which are
designed to reassure people so on the
one that one approach is to to try and
learn from other parts of the world that
have read that have not frightened
countries around them so why Chinese are
quite interested in the European Union
and the idea of regional integration
because they can see that that allowed
Germany to return to the international
to the international order without
scaring people after World War two so
they're sort of experimenting with
embracing it regional integration within
Asia
which has one benefit which is
reassuring the neighbors that China's
not going to crush them and it they have
a stake in China's rise but and the
second benefit of excluding the United
States from the development of the the
new political community they also try
and regional integration to the west
with they've created a thing called the
Shanghai Cooperation Organization with
with Russia which is allowing them to
get involved in Central Asia in a way
that with Russia's blessing because it's
through the the Shanghai Cooperation
Organization second way that they're
thinking about reassuring the world is
the Chinese have become completely
obsessed with the idea of soft power
which is an American idea originally and
they're looking at ways of building
Chinese soft power and of reassuring in
the world that they're making China more
attractive and that's partly by
associating China with some ideas that
already attractive like economic
development pointing to the success that
China's had recently political
sovereignty and also the idea of being
independent from from from Western
interference from the interference of
the outside world and then so that has
led to policies like for example setting
up Confucius Institute around the world
to promote Chinese culture and a Chinese
language and much more sophisticated
Chinese public diplomacy I think they're
I mean Chinese are interested in in
copying some of the things that work
well from the Indian economy there is a
degree of geo strategic competition in
places like Burma where China and India
are both kind of active and trying to
build it into their sphere of influence
and they're also quite keen to make sure
that India doesn't become part of a
balancing coalition with the United
States and Japan so a lot has been done
by the Chinese to rebuild relations with
India because I mean it's only 40 years
it's barely 40 years and that since
China and India were at war with each
other so there was a degree of mistrust
which had to be settled but it is
striking when you go to India how much
more obsessed they are with China than
than the reverse I mean Chinese don't
sit around obsessing about India in the
way the Indians obsess about joining I
suppose that's because the Chinese
economy has been growing a lot faster
than the Indian economy and it China is
a much more powerful country already the
EU and China have one of the most
important economic relationships in the
world the European Union is is China's
most important trading partner it is
also a massive source of investment in
China and it's because China in the u.s.
are so far from each other and because
Europeans don't have a military presence
in the Pacific it's a much less tense
relationship than the relationship
between the United States and China
occasionally the Chinese have visions of
developing a multipolar world and think
that the United Stated States says
preeminence in the world might be
balanced by some kind of alliance
between the European Union and China
they thought that might happen in 2003
after the split over the Iraq war but
then they rapidly realized that that
wasn't going to happen and that if China
tried to split Europe from the US it
would simply end up uniting the
transatlantic partners so at the moment
the relationship is is much more
economic than anything else and it has
been pretty positive in that for most of
the last few years but it is becoming
tenser now because China where the
European Union has now got a bigger
trade deficit with China than the United
States has and a lot of the issues which
cause tension between the US and China
in the economic round like the currency
issue and now actually starting to
become problematic in the EU China
relationship as well